hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ooto
TV the content shown in this video has
been submitted by various players to
ooto TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful
[Music]
owner
fight
[Music]
a
[Applause]
do
[Music]
sh
thank
[Music]
you
oh oh oh my god oh oh oh oh oh yeah fail
oh
no oh oh oh oh my god get off
the
get
[Music]
h
ch
[Music]
h
oh you guys
SM
to
[Music]
want to be featured in ooto TV send in
your Clips by following these steps
before you submit your Clips make sure
the quality of the video is clear put
your IGN as a file name for your video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category don't spam
submissions and don't send folders with
your Clips on avoid full length matches
or just cut the clip you want on the
desired play Until the End of the round
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category you can always find it
on the description of every ooto TV
series Once you upload your video file
if it prompts you to give your name just
put in your
IGM also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay
[Music]
match
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process thanks for
watching don't forget to hit like and be
sure to subscribe for more Tekken
[Music]
content